WITH THEORIA, GAVINEWSOM.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM, THANKS FOR
IN
THE PANDEMIC.OF YOUR
LLS SAE
MORE THAN TH1.5 MILLION
SIGNATURES NEED EE
TO BALLOTRED ON YOURNIA, ANHEEN
THE LOWESTESHOLD OF THE 19
STATES THAT ALW A RECALL I
THE COUNTRY AND ALL YOU NEED IS
A QUARTER OF THE PEOPL
TED FOR DONALD TRUMP GETALL PET.
E USLY.THE SIXT EFFORT  MONTHSIC
GOVERNOR.
THIS ONEPP BECAUSE THEY
GOT AN EXTENSION FM A JUDGE TO
HAVE THE RRE WE'RE TAKING IT
YOE RECALLRTER C
A CERTWAY.
RECALL BACKERS SAY MORE THAN 2M
-VPIRACYYOU A AR
THEORISTS AND -IMMIGRANT
TRUMP CAU?
PROPONENT -- THE LEAD ONENT OF,
PANDEMIC, IS SOMEONE THAT BELIE
IMMIGRANTS.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE THATARLEADOALITE
THIS PETITRED
OUMBERS. PART OF THE, THE
GROUP
CONSPIRACY THEORISTSWHITE
GROUPS, THAT'S
S FACTUAL.
DAY THAT'S THE ORIGINSTH
D U COMBITH NEWT
GINGRICH AND MIKAB
DEVIN NUD NOE RNC
NATHIS RECALL, TIME
YOU'RE GOIN SOMETHING ON THE S
HOTHIS PETITION AND I'M NOT
LEJUST WENT AFTER.
CERTAINLY
CALIFORNIANS WHO SNE
AREN'T ALL TRUMPER
I MEANWEE D
YOURS WHO ARE NOW SUPPORTING TH
FRER
DOING BECAUSE TH THEMEASURES YO.
>> LOOK, I RESPECT THA
IT'S BEEN A DIFFICULT YEAR.
IN HINDSIGHT, YOU E
ALL EXPERTS.
THE REALITY IT WAS A YEAR AGO
ISAS TFIRST STATE TO INITIATA
STAY-AT-HO.
I THINK WE SAVED THOUSANDS AND
LIVESHE END OF THE Y GHWE'RS N.
I'M JUST AT A SCHO
9,000 PLUSOOE EITHER
REOPENED OR ABOUT TOWE'VE ADMIN
WE VACCINE, 464,000 JUST DAY, A.
DOLLARS TO HELP GET OUR SMALBUS
COUNTIES HAVE REOPEN. 58
EN I EP DEEPLY T LIGHT A
RESPECTFUL TO ALL THE S
THAT PEOPLE HAVE FELER
LAST YEAR.
>>BEEN O THE
REN HAD ONLY AROUND
50,000 SIGTURES UNU
INFAMOUSLY ATT MULTIPLOT
AT THAT FANCY CH
LAUNDRY OR WHATEVER IT'S CAL
LOBBYISE YOWE
FORNIANS THAT TH
SH HOME.
SO 5005,000 SIGNATURES
BEFORE YOU HAD THAT DINNER
MONTAT
SIGNUR BECOME ME
LIKE 500,000.
I KNOWVEYOU HAVE  FOR THAT DINN.
YOMISTAKE TO GO,
WAS A
TID I DON'T INK YOU'VE SWERED I?
>> WELL, AS A FRIEND O Y, HIS H
50th BIRTHDAY, RESTAURTS WERE
OPENTHE STATE.
I WASNG  NOT EERE I WAS WROND O
AN A HIGH LEVEL
ACCOUNTABILITY, THE CRITICSMANE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THEY COULD
GET THIS RECALL SUPPORTED, ANDN
TH $3 MILLIOOF MONEY, SOME C
DIS OF THE C,
FROM THE
IA, SOD. COMPLICATED AS TO WHY G
TH.
YOU REGRET THE FACT THAT THEREO
D BEEN P
SOMETHINOR
>> WERE OPEN IN THE OF THE STAT.
THAT WAS NEITHER HERE NOR THERED
THE TABLE ANTHASANY PELE
INCONSISTENT WITH WHAT I WAS SI.
I'VE MADE THIS CLEAR AD
NAUSEUM OCCASIONS.
A AND I HAVEN'T
MADE HAD A MISLIKE THAT BE
OR SINCE.
I OWWE'RE HUMAN.N MOVING ON DOG
GHLE DAY TO
OUR KIDS BACINOOL, GETPEOPLE VA
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
NATION RIGHT N A9% SECOND GHESTN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THERS AT 4%.
DO YOU THINK THAT ANY OF YOUR
RESTRICTNST TOR.UNSIGHT IS
ALLYEAR WN'T A
YEAR A, F YOUR COVID
RESTRICTIONS TOO TGH?
WE HAVE LOWEDES ITY DAOWER THAAL
THE VAST MAJORITTH
TES, MUCH LOWER THAN PLACE
LIKE FLORIDA AND TEXAS.
I BELIEVE WE'VE SAVED LIVES.
D BY AND HELD
AND LE
IDEOLOGICAL, OPEN ARGUMENT.
INTERESTED IN EVIDENCE.
THSTION,E,O YO PE HOSPITALITY AT
ALL BUSINESS
DISPROPORTIONATE IT AN
THAT'S BEEN REFLECTE
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS.
RE GOOD NEWS.
WE'RE RUNNING
THE STATE.
E OF
SURPLUSES IN STE
WE JUST LED THNCE
AGAIN IN OUR INNOVATION R ECONOE
THS WIE RADICALLTHAN THEY ARE TL
ISTRATION FOR
PRESIDING OVER $30 BILLION
SUSPECTED UNEMPLOYMENT FRAUD
Y
ECONOMICALLYI UNDERSTAND YOU WE
IN CHARGE AS THE GOVERNOR.
THIS WASMONEY,LIONS G
SCAMMERS.
WRONG?
DO YAKFO
>> YEAH, IT'S HAPPACROSS THE UN.
IT DESERVES A LOT MORE ATTENTION
THAN IT'GETTINDIFFERENCE IN CAL.
MOST OTHERTE NOT DONE
IMAGAT, NO STRETCH OF THE
EN IN CA
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT WAS UNFORTUNATEHOWEVER,
IS THERE WAS THI
AND IT HAD TO COME OUT
YMENT
ASSIST, UNEMPLNTTHAT THERE WAS
MODEST AMOUNT UD BUT THE
S D NEW
ANTHING THAT EVERYSTAT IS,
HAVE EXPERIENCED, AND -- AFFERE
AT LEAST PUSCK AGA
N OF ADDITIONAL FRAUD.UT A PROG
METHIS IS DIFFICULT STUFF AND I
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRAONTIONAL CO
WEE THRNATIONAL
RINGS DOWNTO DEFRAUD T LDING THI
YOU YOURSELF HAVE NOT GOTTEN THE
VACCE.
BUHICCE,N YOU DO, WILL HE ON IF
YOU SHOWOUF TAKING IT
NCE HESITANCY IS FRANKLY A
SUL OVER THENTA IT'S NOTUST THE
MAGA FOLKS WNTI-VAXXER,
HOME STATE SO ARE YOU GOING TO
SHOW YOURSELF GETTING THE SHOT?
NOT DIFFOS
ATND
ANTI-VAXXERS.
WARD TO THAT
MY TURN COMES UP HOPEF
MAY 1sRYBODY'S TURN WILL  UAY 1
FORWARTO TAKING WHATEVER
ONE OF THE VACCINES I DO
G TO THE EXTEN
TIME IS THE J&CHOIY TH
ONE.AID I THINK AT T END OF
THE DAY,OLITICIANS MATTER  MATTO
NE SOMEONE
THAT SOMEONE ELSUSTS T WITH  C
DOUST DECLINTHE .
THAT'S A MORE CHALLENGINANXING
RACISMNDTHC AND RACIAL
LINES.
>> AND SO YOU TALKEDT Y 1st DELI
ST T UP VACCINE IBILITY FOR ALM
SO
E MAY 1s
DEADLINE?INVESTIO
WI THERE?
>> WE JUST INCREASED THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERYONE 16-67
C
CO AS PEOPLE  INTELLECTUAL DISA
AND THIS IS SOMETHING WE NEED TO
TALK MORT AS WELL ASACCINE ALLO
IN THIS COUNTRY,, AI
WE'RE LOOKING  SCARCITY LLION V.
OUR ONLY CONSTRAINUP
MANUFACTAS THAT MANUFA